دعا الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد مجلس النواب
الشعب الجديد الى عقيسته الافتتاحيه اليوم
الاثنين وذلك وفق امر رئاسي نشرته الجديده
الرسميه حيث ان الدستور التونسيه ينص على
ضروره دعوه الرئيس انعقاد البرلمان بعد
اسبوعين من تصريح هيئه الانتخابات
بالنتائج النهائيه للتشريعيه التشريعيه
هذا وكانت هيئه الانتخابات اعلنت في
الخامس والعشرين من فبراير الماضي عن فوز
154 مترشحا بمقاعد في البرلمان بعد تنظيم
جولتين ويتكون البرلمان الجديد من 161
عضوا لكنه سينطلق في اعماله منقوصا من
سبعه نواب على خلفيه عدم تسجيل ترشحات في
عدد من الدوائر الانتخابيه خارج البلاد
مشاهدينا من تونس انضموا الينا الصحفيين
حمداوي اهلا بك وكيف تبدو اجواء ما قبل
انعقاد جثه الاولى للبرلمان التونسي
الجديده وما الذي يدور خلف الكواليس
نعم صباح الخير دقائق قليله تفصلنا عن
موعد الجلسه الافتتاحيه هنا في باردو في
مقر مجلس نواب الشعب على اجراء تبدو عاديه
باعتبار ان هنالك تواجد امني مكثف على طول
الطريق المؤديه الى هنا ساحه باردو قربه
العاصمه تونس هنالك تواجد ايضا لعديد من
وسائل الاعلام المحليه والدوليه التي تغطي
هذا الحدث الهاب الذي كان هنالك تيره اشهر
طويله كان العمل على هذا المجلس النواب
بعد انتخاب اعضائه اعضائه في السابع عشر
من ديسمبر الماضي وبعد انتفاء كل الشروط
القانونيه من الطعون وغيرها وثمه اخيرا
قام رئيس الجمهوريه بدعوه مجلس النواب
الانعقاد اليوم الاثنين الثالث عشر من شهر
مارس وفقا للترتيب التي اعلن عنها مجلس
نواب الامس فان هذه الجلسه ستكون برئاسه
اكبر النواب سنا وبمساعده اصغرهم واصغرهن
سيقوم النواب بصفه جماعيه بتلاوه القسم ثم
اختيار لجنه للسهر على فرز والاعداد
الترشحات لرئاسه مجلس نواب الشعب بصفه
دائمه ثم ستقوم بتلقي الترشحات وفرزها على
دورتين اذا لم يترسح يتحصل عفوا من
المترشحين على اغلبيه الاصوات ستكون
تنافس المحموم على رئه البرلمان
من هم ابرز المرشحين والاوفر حظا بينهم
ايضا لتسمعين النسرين
بالفعل هنالك عديد الاسماك التي تم
تداولها خلال الاسابيع الماضيه خاصه بعد
الاعلان عن نتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
التشريعيه لكن الاقرب من الاسماء
المتداوله هو عميد المحامين السابق
ابراهيم بودرباله باعتباره اعلن انه ينوي
اترشح الى هذا المنصب وايضا هنالك عديد
الاسماء ربما تكون من حركه الشعب التي
تحظى بنصيب وافر من اعداد البرلمانيين
الذين فازوا في هذه الانتخابات لكن الى حد
هذه اللحظه لا نعلم عدد المترشحين او من
هم باعتبار ان الجلسه لم تنطلق بان ايضا
الترشح سيكون علنيا ولكن الانتخاب هو ما
سيكون سريا خلال هذه الجلسه الاولى
الافتتاحيه هل من مواقف سجلت من قبل
المعارضه اذا احدث الهام وهل من دعوات
لتحركات احتجاجيه على سبيل المثال في هذا
اليوم ايضا
حقيقه المعارضه لم تقم باي دعوه للتحرك او
الاحتجاج خلال هذا اليوم ايضا هي لم تصدر
اي موقف لي دعوه المجلس للاناقات باعتبار
ان هذا التاريخ هو حتمي باعتبار سيروره
رزنامه التي كان اعلن عنه منذ اشهر طويله
فانه بعد الطعون سيتم بالتالي بصفه اليه
دعوه مجلس النواب للانعقاد لكن المعارضه
الى حد هذه اللحظه لم تصدر اي بيانات او
تدعو للاحتجاج بالشارع وبالتالي الامور
هنا في ساحه باردو تصير بصفه طبيعيه جدا